we've now seen the results of this
commission carried over the last two
years very forensic work 2 500 pages
contained in that report and quite
frankly the numbers are staggering the
estimation from the commission is that
over the last 70 years
330 000 children were abused in the
catholic church and it wasn't just abuse
committed by uh priests but other
members of the clergy and also people
connected uh with the church and the
report concludes that there was a
systemic cover-up over all these decades
and i think the really worrying thing is
that the cover-up continued until uh
recent years now the report says that um
thousands of those thousands of victims
uh who were subjected to sexual abuse
some 60 percent of them suffered
significant problems in their later
lives mental health problems sexual
problems so you can see the lasting
damage of sexual abuse the report has
made some 45 recommendations uh to
improve things to protect
children in the future i think the
tragic thing is though given the passage
of time this report is looking into
sexual abuse over seven decades that in
terms of any prosecutions uh they are
very very limited indeed the reporters
put forward
around 20
alleged cases where there is still
evidence of people are alive to pursue
prosecutions but this is
really damaging and dabbing in terms of
the catholic church in france other
nations have had some would say they're
reckoning in terms of child abuse in the
catholic church america ireland
england also i think many of the victims
would say the reckoning has been way too
long coming in france
and michelle that the victims that have
been cited uh
are they both male and female or mainly
boys
um what we understand is that 80
of the victims uh were male so some uh
women girls were also involved but 80
percent of them
were male uh victims and as i say uh the
report concludes rather disturbingly
that some 60 percent of those uh went on
to experience very significant problems
later in their life as the result of
abuse that was committed by priest
clergy and others involved in the
catholic church and it was abuse that
was um covered up it was a systemic
cover-up according to the commission
author